de ce retard
alors nos collègues vont sans doute nous
alors chers martial vous êtes directeur
du Centre d'études de la vie politique
française vous êtes un habitués de nos
de nos conversations et de nos éditions
bonheur parce que je crois que nous
avons ici besoin d'être éclairé et
d'avoir des grilles de lecture sur des
des choses que nous constatons et qu'il
nous convient de savoir expliquer pour
mieux comprendre et aider à la
transformation alors vous avez présenté
votre quatrième enquête auprès des
maires de France au Congrès des Maires
de novembre dernier ce qu'on ressent
c'est cette notion
d'inquiétude alors une inquiétude qui
peut parfois certains disent être mais
qu'en tout cas
elle nous semble qu'elle prend
aujourd'hui une autre une autre
dimension c'est un peu celle de
l'inquiétude d'un monde qui vient et
déjà en 2020 votre ouvrage s'appelait
mer au bord de la crise de mer la
démocratie locale peut-elle survivre
alors même que vous vous disiez ce que
ce
à quoi nous croyons c'est à dire que la
réapproprieration par les Français de
leur territoire notamment après la prise
covid c'est vous le disiez le seul
paravent à l'implosion des démocratiques
et vous le dites que l'État à la fois
exerce un rôle un peu de de contraintes
et de domination pour les élus qui sont
pris entre Nantes entre cet état c'est
aussi l'intercommunalité qui parfois
leur paraît encore un peu dévorante et
omnipotent donc
cher martial on a une question toute
simple à vous poser quand il
continuerons non je continue en nous
voilà je je m'en sors vraiment je suis
très contente à trouver des citoyens en
capacité de se dévouer au bien commun
c'est-à-dire à se présenter à des
élections quand on sait qu'en 2020 110
communes n'ont pas eu de candidats aux
élections donc martial hier vous
participiez à une des auditions de la
mission sur la commune
qui qui se tient au Sénat est vraiment
merci de nous donner ce temps pour nous
qu'un temps un peu de pause de réflexion
et de mise en perspective merci martial
je ne serai pas plus loin
de mon point de vue assez satisfaisant
près de 15% en général c'est c'est
souvent moins pour les pour les élus
avec malgré tout un
taux de réponse très très faible pour
les communes de plus de 50 000 habitants
mais c'est le mode de passation c'est
une enquête administrée en ligne et je
dois dire qu'au-delà de 30000 habitants
il est rare que ce soit le ou la mer qui
répond directement donc je préfère ne
pas avoir de réponse plutôt que celle du
directeur de cabinet ou conseiller du
cabinet donc on va changer la méthode à
partir de cette année en septembre
prochain où je vais moi-même d'ailleurs
organiser les entretiens face à face
avec une quarantaine de mères sur la
strate des plus de 30 000 habitants
donc nous avons eu en septembre et
octobre 2022 plus de 5000 réponses sur
cette enquête qui portait sur trois
grands thèmes le premier alors il y
avait une actualité qui était la
question de la de la gestion
locale de la crise énergétique
on a on a presque déjà oublié que il y a
quatre mois c'était le sujet
extrêmement prenant et puis il y a comme
une forme aujourd'hui de de d'oubli de
ce que cela a produit dans dans les
municipalités il y avait un deuxième un
deuxième champ d'étude qui portait sur
alors qui rejoint le propos introductif
que vous avez que vous avez indiqué
Françoise
[Musique]
de l'ensemble des équipes des conseils
municipaux
alors sur le premier sur le premier
sujet crise énergétique
en fait il y a pas de surprise
qu'est-ce qu'on a observé on a observé
que
les les maires ont fait preuve en fait
de beaucoup de responsabilités par
rapport à ce qu'il aurait été demandé
et on voit que les actions les
interrogées sur un certain nombre
d'actions qu'ils entendaient mettre en
place je rappelle c'est une enquête
septembre octobre on n'a pas encore une
on parle à cette époque là la première
ministre parle de coupure d'électricité
à envisager à partir du mois de janvier
février donc quand on interroge les
maires on les interroge sur une
situation
à la fois faite d'incertitude
mais aussi de leur côté de de
responsabilité et politique mais aussi
d'exigence financière
parce que ils sont déjà très nombreux à
s'inquiéter des effets sur sur leur
budget
ce qui ressort très massivement et en
particulier pour les maires de communes
de moins de 3500 habitants
c'est j'ai presque une un raisonnement
de bon sens très simplement en disant on
nous avons des équipements collectifs
moins de 3500 habitants ils n'ont pas
tous
des équipements de grande ampleur
gymnase terrain de sport avec
l'éclairage mais il y a quand même pour
pour beaucoup le souci un de réduire
l'éclairage des installations sportives
lorsqu'elles existent
la réduction veut pas dire on passe de
tout éclairer à
noir nuit complète pendant 4 mois ou 5
mois c'est une réduction de l'amplitude
horaire c'est une réorganisation
des moments d'activité alors on est dans
l'hiver mais on essaye de réduire les
périodes d'activité nocturnes c'est
éteindre l'éclairage public
ces éléments là c'est plus de 70% des
mers qui souscrivent pleinement assez à
ses actions en revanche
il y a
il y a un rejet très massif de la part
des mers de ce qui concerne la fermeture
la fermeture de ces équipements ils sont
fortement opposés ils préfèrent trouver
des mesures plus équilibrées tout comme
la question de réduction on a posé une
question sur la réduction de l'ensemble
des moyens communaux au service
communaux véhicules notamment
là aussi il y a il y a un rejet de cette
de cette possibilité alors qu'est-ce
qu'on en a retiré comme comme analyse
sur la
l'action l'action des mers en cette
période de crise énergétique
c'était au fond ce qu'on avait déjà
identifié pendant la crise
et quand je dis cela c'est c'est je veux
pas exagérer ou amplifier une situation
mais
ça correspond un
sentiment de laisser pour compte
on doit trouver des solutions parce que
on ne les trouve pas pour nous c'est ce
qu'on retrouve dans les verbes intimes
de nos enquêtes et un deuxième point de
comparaison avec la crise covid qui va
m'amener à discuter cette cette belle
question de l'égalité versus
versus l'autonomie ou
la décentralisation les mers ne
souscrivent absolument pas à l'idée
d'une politique uniforme sur tout le
territoire en matière de réduction
énergétique
et ça c'est un c'est un c'est un c'est
pas simplement un mouvement d'humeur
c'est une réalité très objectivable de
la difficulté à devoir appliquer des
recommandations ou voir des instructions
des préfectures sur ces mesures de de
sobriété énergétique
ça et je termine sur ce premier point ça
a un effet qui me semble important à
partager avec vous
c'est que les conséquences financières
pour un certain nombre de municipalités
pas toutes ça dépend comment elles ont
évidemment
négocier leur contrats d'énergie mais on
a remarqué qu'il y avait une incidence à
prendre en compte un moyen terme mais
pas à long terme un moyen terme c'est
tout d'abord
un décalage ou un report dans le temps
de l'ensemble des plans d'investissement
environnement
ça c'est le premier c'est le premier
point
à souligner deuxièmement beaucoup de
mères sont
prêts également à réduire
drastiquement l'ensemble des achats de
fournitures et prestations de services
donc quand on parle d'ingéniorité
territoriale parfois dont certaines
municipalités ne disposent pas on voit
que ça aussi des conséquences pour les
plus petites communes et enfin
il y a un élément à l'opposé de ce que
je viens de dire pour lesquels les mers
quel que soit la situation ne sont pas
prêts à renoncer c'est au recrutement
personnel y compris contractuel et
surtout contractuel
donc on voit qu'il y a il y a des
éléments par voie de répercussion sur le
plan budgétaire qui ne peuvent pas être
mesurés maintenant et apprécié
maintenant je crois que c'est beaucoup
trop tôt ce sont parfois des des
montages une architecture financière
notamment sur les contrats d'énergie qui
ne permettent pas d'y voir très très
clair aujourd'hui deuxième point
dans dans l'esprit de ce que j'évoquais
à l'instant
ça fait plus de 4 ans que j'essaye de
travailler cette question qui me paraît
essentielle de
oui de l'opposition entre
décentralisation et égalité moi je
l'avais remarqué dans le cadre de
l'enquête puisqu'on interroge les maires
une fois tous les deux ans mais nous
interrogeons une fois tous les deux ans
également en décalé avec une enquête
miroir un large échantillon de plus de
10000 Français sur leur propre
représentation du rôle de la commune
dans leur vie de résident mais aussi
dans cet espace de on va dire de
citoyenneté
il y a deux ans j'avais essayé de tester
un petit peu le niveau de de
connaissance des Français sur Le la
décentralisation bon
c'est un terme qui le
connaissent
comme tout à chacun un mot dans le
dictionnaire
en revanche
la compréhension du terme de
décentralisation se limite
essentiellement alors vous pouvez me
dire c'est déjà cela mais
essentiellement une conception assez
juridique telle que le terme s'est
installé élan alors non pas qu'ils
étaient dans l'attente de célébrer le
40e anniversaire des lois de
décentralisation mais il y a une
connaissance extrêmement sommaire donc
on les a un petit peu
poussé dans dans des retranchements de
réponse en essayant de mettre en
opposition l'idée de l'égalité
répu européenne et territoriale à
travers une voilà plusieurs exemples de
politiques publiques locales
pour lesquelles finalement les Français
sont attachés à l'égalité mais
il s'en éloigne dès lors que la question
de l'efficacité de ces politiques
publiques locales n'est pas au
rendez-vous donc ça c'est vraiment le
point d'achoppement égalité oui s'il y a
l'efficacité mais on préfère et le terme
il faut être très prudent parce que il y
a aussi
le panel qu'on interroge dix mille
personnes
parfois une ambiguïté entre le terme de
décentralisation
différenciation déconcentration pour les
Français ça correspond globalement à la
même idée d'accord
cette différenciation elle est justifiée
pleinement justifiée et ils sont prêts à
renoncer à l'égalité si les politiques
publiques sont adaptées au territoire
alors le propos caricatural consisterait
à dire évidemment une politique pour
pour la moyenne montagne une politique
pour un territoire du littoral on peut
de choses en commun sur un certain
nombre de de
champs d'intervention
des exécutifs locaux oui mais ça va
beaucoup plus loin ça concerne des
questions comme le logement sa question
ça concerne des questions comme la
fiscalité et ça concerne aussi des
questions très très basiques de l'école
donc qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'on
retire aujourd'hui vraiment on démarre
ce sujet on retire deux choses
importantes le premier c'est que il y a
globalement
une préférence très très forte
en matière de décentralisation
c'est-à-dire que les mers sont un mers
sur deux interrogés
déclare
vouloir aller beaucoup plus loin que
l'État aille beaucoup plus loin en
matière de liberté ou de compétences
locales un maire sur deux donc c'est un
chiffre qui qui de mon point de vue est
très important cet esprit
décentralisateurs des mers
s'accompagne aussi de deux autres
phénomènes qui est que ils sont prêts à
60% de maire à considérer que l'État
doit complètement renoncé aux
compétences qu'il a des centralisé
d'accord ça c'est le premier élément et
toujours dans cette ce sentiment de de
enfin de volontarisme décentralisateur
ça va de pair avec un avec une
observation qui est plus ancienne
celle-ci
pour les maires consistant à penser que
aujourd'hui il y a beaucoup trop de
doublons entre les services de l'État et
ceux des collectivités territoriales et
donc ils attendent d'un mouvement
décentralisateur une correction de ces
doublons c'est aussi penser comme ça
pour beaucoup de beaucoup de beaucoup
demeure pour terminer sur ce sujet
décentralisation et et
égalité je crois qu'on a tort de penser
que toutes les politiques publiques
locales doivent être doivent être
sanctionnés du saut de l'égalité
ce que je vous dis là il peut paraître
provocant mais on s'illusionne je crois
fortement sur l'idée de l'égalité
territoriale elle n'est pas souhaitée
par une majorité de maire et elle n'est
pas souhaitée par une majorité de
Français en revanche
si l'efficacité de l'action publique
locale et confirmé elle est elle est
perçue elle est tangible alors ça ne
pose plus de questions d'égalité
l'égalité va se ramène parfois convoqué
pour justifier ou légitimer l'action
publique locale parce qu'elle est perçue
comme efficace et l'action publique
locale
aujourd'hui dans dans les verbes intimes
qu'on a recueilli c'est surtout la
question des services publics locaux
vous voyez c'est pas tant une question
de la qualité de la voirie de
l'aménagement de l'entretien non c'est
une question des véritablement des
politiques publiques locales et donc
l'école j'insiste vraiment l'école le
logement et le transport sur toutes ces
transformations autour des mobilités là
il y a véritablement un sujet
j'étais peut-être un peu trop long le
point dernier grand blog sur les
tensions démocratiques
alors oui il y avait un sujet sur
lesquels d'ailleurs je crois lors de ma
précédente venue auprès de votre
délégation on avait évoqué la question
faut-il s'alerter de la hausse de
l'abstention lors des élections locales
et je me souviens qu'on avait une
discussion autour d'un est-ce un
phénomène passager c'était après la les
élections municipales de mars et juin
2020 période covid dont on ne sait
toujours pas vrai dire aucun travail
académique n'a permis d'identifier si ce
déficit de 20 points aux élections
municipales de devilmain de 2020 était
dû à un phénomène
covid ou bien un phénomène structurel de
ce qui pourrait être la tendance à
observer en 2026 alors on peut le
regarder autrement puisqu'on n'a pas la
réponse
on peut le regarder autrement le taux de
participation dans les communes
pardon le taux de participation aux
élections présidentielles et législative
de 2022 dans les communes où le taux de
participation était déjà le plus faible
municipal
et bien on a une magnifique corrélation
qui dit corrélation ne dit pas causalité
mais effectivement c'est confirmé que
dans les territoires où il y a eu une
forte baisse en 2020 elle s'est
confirmée à l'occasion de ces deux
scrutins y compris élection
présidentielle j'insiste parce que c'est
quand même celle sur lequel on peut
repérer des tendances plus lourdes
donc ça c'est le gérer c'est le décor
quelle est la le regard porté par les
mers entre 2020 et 2022 en 2020 je
reprends les les données un maire sur
deux estimé que
c'est un c'est un phénomène très
inquiétant dès 2020 et qui était un
signe de désintérêt politique y compris
au plan local un maire sur deux
deux ans plus tard après la séquence
présidentielle législative c'est 8 mères
sur 10 80% qui disent effectivement ce
qu'on avait peut-être
identifié pour 30% d'entre eux comme
n'étant pas un problème c'était purement
passager parce que Chris covid
aujourd'hui considère que c'est beaucoup
plus structurel et qu'il y a ici une
marque d'un d'un désintérêt politique
qui qui grandit
à vitesse grand V
quand je dis un mur sur deux est inquiet
ça veut dire que un Mr sur deux n'était
pas n'était pas inquiet il n'était pas
inquiet pour une raison
importante qui était de dire mais les
Français restent attachés à leur mère
donc il peut se produire une sorte de
décélération pour les autres élections
locales régionales départementales
c'est la torial peut-être un directement
donc mais il regarde quand même ce qui
se passe
aujourd'hui c'est plus le cas ils sont
eux-mêmes conscients que l'élection
municipale peut produire ce qu'on entend
y compris pour des élections nationales
une crise de légitimité de leur élection
et donc à partir du moment où il y
aurait un procès en illégitimité de leur
élection au regard du nombre d'électeurs
parce que en dessous souvent quand même
lorsqu'on veut instruire ce procès en
illégitimité on ne raisonne plus sur les
voies exprimées mais uniquement sur les
suffrages inscrits
et effectivement en
2020 et notamment un ministre régalien
important avait souffert de cette crise
d'illégitimité en étant élu dans une
commune du nord de la France donc
je crois que cette question de
du de la participation pour les
élections municipales et est à prendre
très au sérieux parce que même si les
maires restent les représentants
préférés des Français à défaut d'avoir
un taux de participation on est dans le
on est dans on est dans une cinquième
République où le fait majoritaire s'est
imposé donc qui dit fait majoritaire dit
une portée fortement symbolique du 50%
. vous pouvez tourner les chiffres dans
tous les sens si on vous annonce que
vous avez été élu avec simplement 45%
des inscrits vous vous introduisez un
doute sur la qualité de l'élection
c'est c'est inévitable en tout cas elle
peut être un élément un argument saisi
par des oppositions
à côté de l'abstention dont on pourra
peut-être revenir sur les sur les causes
il y a il y avait un sujet qui nous
semblait intéressant c'était de vérifier
si le pays effectivement connaît au plan
local
est-ce que le plan local est une chambre
de résonance de ce qu'on observait au
plan national en terme de de tension de
polarisation des opinions alors je dois
vous dire que j'ai été très très surpris
des résultats je pensais que au plan
local
les mères avaient une vision beaucoup
plus
je veux dire beaucoup plus douce ou
beaucoup plus responsable
vis-à-vis du comportement de leurs
administrés pas du tout pas du tout
on a 50%
je pourrais décomposer mais 50% des mers
qui nous indiquent que oui il y a un
durcissement des opinions politiques ils
observent que effectivement
dans leur commune les citoyens aux
opinions politiques opposées différentes
ont de plus en plus de difficultés à
discuter entre eux donc il le il le
perçoivent par alors ce sont pas des
altercations
violentes et physique c'est pas cela
c'est des signaux dans les discussions à
l'école auprès des commerçants dans les
associations sportives et culturelles il
y a de la tension d'accord
deuxième illustration de ce de cette
polarisation politique
parce que moi j'avais été très surpris
de voir au premier tour de l'élection
2022 notamment pour l'électorat de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon
je sais pas si vous avez en tête ces
cartes électorales mais au premier tour
on voit une grande bande qui va
quasiment de la Lozère jusque
dans le Vaucluse avec Jean-Luc Mélenchon
en tête dans un territoire des
territoires qui jusqu'à lors était
n'était pas des territoires
historiquement du Parti communiste
j'ai regardé Georges Marchais au premier
tour en 1981 il est rarement en tête
donc il fallait comprendre pourquoi il y
avait une progression et ça a été le
fait déclencheur de ce travail auprès
des mers
ce sont aussi des territoires parce
qu'on parle beaucoup de la diagonale du
vide
mais il y a plusieurs diagonales en
France du vide il s'est passé simplement
celle qui irait du sud-ouest au nord-est
on a d'autres diagonales celles-ci en
est une c'est pas vraiment une diagonale
c'est plutôt une radiale et qui est
marqué par deux sujets qui expliquent ce
durcissement des opinions politiques 1
les inégalités territoriales bien avant
les inégalités économiques et sociales
la relégation territoriale et et très
très mal vécu et elle produit cette
tension très très forte entre entre les
citoyens
autrement dit des citoyens qui
pourraient s'en sortir et d'autres qui
sont presque assignés à cette fracture
territoriale
et puis la deuxième la deuxième
[Musique]
cause de ce durcissement je crois que
la question du la question du grand
débat national et du moment gilet jaune
n'est pas totalement épuisée dans
beaucoup de territoires
je crois qu'on a eu tort de penser qu'on
pouvait
apporter des réponses simplement en
ouvrant des selles polyvalentes ou des
sels municipales et et laisser les gens
discuter entre eux ils n'ont pas
délibéré ils ont éventuellement discuté
et dans la discussion tout le monde
n'avait pas vu au chapitre je pense que
dans ces territoires on observe de
nouveau aujourd'hui et 2022 est une est
une bonne illustration d'un finalement
d'un chapitre qui n'est pas qui n'est
pas fermé et pour les mères je moi je
vois une difficulté c'est à dire que
et vous l'avez peut-être constaté
j'étais très surpris pendant la campagne
2020 serre dans un contexte très
particulier que la France c'était
totalement converti
à
la politique de la concertation le
nombre de professions de foi
de programme ou le mot concertation
apparaissait
de la part de beaucoup d'équipes laisser
penser que c'était la pierre
philosophale à tous les problèmes et
qu'ils allaient être réglés par ce que
d'excellents professionnels de la
concertation avec convaincu les équipes
municipales qu'ils avaient des kits sur
mesure pour faire de la concertation
j'exagère un petit peu mais mon propos
est libre ce matin
c'est une double illusion la
concertation elle se décrète pas avec
des kits à conduire clé en main
ça c'est le premier élément ce qui va
d'ailleurs
m'amener à je pense il faut réfléchir
sur la question de la formation mais
deuxième illusion
c'est celle des citoyens laissant penser
que
finalement on règle tous les problèmes
d'action publique municipales par de la
concertation
d'ailleurs je l'ai pas évoqué mais sur
les mesures énergétiques on a posé la
question aux mères est-ce que pour
certaines de ces mesures qui peuvent
paraître
difficile brutal c'est un changement
rapide est-ce que vous allez mener des
consultations ou des concertations 93%
disent non
non parce que j'ai été élu et donc je
suis en quelque sorte en capacité
d'exercer ma responsabilité politique
laissant entendre que sur chaque sujet
où il y aurait potentiellement des
tensions s'il faut convoquer une
procédure dite de concertation de
délibération de participation les maires
s'interrogent sur le principe même du
suffrage universel
qui les a conduits pour beaucoup comme
d’entre eux déjà à faire un acte
extrêmement volontaire en termes de
d'engagement mais si ensuite chacune des
décisions doit faire l'objet d'un d'un
double ou d'un triple
un sentiment de la population il
s'interroge sur véritablement la
fonction la fonction de maire
je termine par un dernier point dans ce
volet tension démocratique cette fois-ci
du côté du côté des élus par rapport au
sujet de la violence
alors
je sais que le Sénat avait conduit cette
enquête en 2019 de mémoire ce sondage
auprès des auprès des élus sur la
violence avec un taux de réponse qui
était tout à fait
satisfaisant et on avait observé de
mémoire je crois que c'était près de
1600 élus qui avait signalé avoir été
depuis l'exercice de leur dernier mandat
de violence au sens très très large nous
dans l'enquête on est sensiblement sur
la même jauge avec
aujourd'hui
63% de maire interrogée qui nous disent
avoir été victime d'incivilité
63% un politesse agression verbale
37% d'injures ou d'insultes
63% de menaces verbales ou écrite et
enfin
30 30% d'attaques sur les réseaux
sociaux
alors évidemment ces chiffres sont
très élevés
on n'est pas sur les violences physiques
sur les violences physiques je suis très
prudent parce que oui l'AMF avec le
concours de la gendarmerie nationale a
mis sur pied ces dispositifs et on a on
a des voilà une quantification
qui est en évolution en progression
mais je suis très prudent parce que on
sait combien il est difficile pour un
maire de révéler une agression physique
parce que ça touche aussi à la question
de l'autorité qui exerce le maire ça
touche aussi une question de la justice
beaucoup de maires plusieurs entretiens
un témoignages de mer qui me disent mais
pourquoi porter plainte quand je sais
que le temps de l'instruction et le
temps de la justice ne me garantit
garantira pas
finalement l'absence de représailles
pendant cette période donc je préfère ne
pas porter plainte ne pas déposer
plainte et en même temps gérer alors
c'est rarement seul mais gérer avec mon
conseil municipal cette question est ne
pas mettre de l'huile sur le feu c'est
l'expression qui revient très souvent ne
pas mettre de l'huile sur le feu par un
dépôt de plainte
moi j'en retire deux deux analyses la
première et ça a été évoqué hier la
mission d'information sur l'avenir de la
commune et du maire
je ne pense pas qu'on peut simplement
conclure à ce qui se passe dans la
société rejaillit forcément du côté des
élus une société plus violente
n'a pas nécessairement il n'y a pas un
phénomène mécanique qui conduirait à une
violence
exponentielle du côté des élus donc je
crois que c'est une autre cause que
simplement
une violence généralisée dans la société
en revanche et ça rejoint mon point sur
autonomie décentralisation
l'élim municipal est le maire ces
adjoints et aujourd'hui
l'élu le plus visible
sa visibilité
qui est un atout puisque c'est aussi une
des raisons qui contribue à faire du
maire le représentant préféré il y a un
corollaire c'est que cette visibilité
produit aussi un effet je dirais
paratonnerre de la part de
d'administrer
certaines de ces violences ne sont pas
le fait d'administrer résidant sur la
commune il faut pas il faut pas
l'oublier non plus donc ce travail moi
je j'espère mais on verra j'espère que
et le ministère de l'Intérieur et de le
ministère de la Justice nous aiderons à
documenter à objectiver ce travail sur
les violences parce que encore une fois
je trouve que c'est
le travail réalisé par la gendarmerie et
en termes de prévention et en termes
d'accompagnement et
nécessaire et semble fonctionner mais on
est très très loin d'avoir
circonscrit l'ampleur du phénomène et
puis deuxième et dernier réflexion sur
la question des des violences
je
pense qu'il y a une autre violence
très très forte violence symbolique
subie par le maire
c'est celle de
[Musique]
c'est la question de l'absentéisme du
conseil municipal
j'en parle volontairement à ce moment là
parce qu'on l'a on l'a questionné j'ai
été frappé moi j'avais que des éléments
des signaux faibles de maire qui me
disait on parle on parle de la démission
des maires mais vous devriez aussi
regarder attentivement ce qui se passe
du côté des conseillers municipaux qui
démissionnent ou ceux qui ne démissionne
pas mais déserte les conseils municipaux
alors je me souviens avoir répondu à un
maire de l'Eure en lui disant
un je n'avais pas d'éléments pour pour
quantifier tout cela je vous vraiment
vous mettez sur une bonne piste parce
que moi je l'ai remarqué et je
connaissais bien ce maire sachant qu'il
était également conseillé communautaire
donc je moi j'ai observé plutôt qu'il y
avait beaucoup d'absentéisme de la part
des maires dans les réunions des
intercos
et certains m'avaient dit oui mais quand
même faire 50 km pour aller à une
réunion où j'ai pas voix au chapitre je
préfère m'abstenir
et donc je l'avais pris au mot disons on
va on va on va essayer à travers ces
enquêtes ces enquêtes attention ce n'est
pas
je dirais c'est impossible d'être
exhaustif c'est du déclaratif mais quand
on interroge quand on a plus de 5000
réponses ça commence à devenir
intéressant et donc oui il y a un
absentéisme municipal de la part des
conseillers dans dans l'enquête vous
avez j'ai 40
% des mers qui nous disent que depuis
leur mandat qui a démarré en 2020 40%
nous disent qu'ils ont déjà
au moins voilà je prends les chiffres un
absentéisme entre 10 et 25% des
conseillers municipaux
dès le début du mandat oui et vous avez
alors
l'absentéisme fort qu'on a qualifié
entre 25 et 50% des séances du conseil
municipal c'est 4% des mers bon alors
c'est peu mais quand même c'est pas
c'est pas négligeable rapporter au
nombre de nombre de communes et à
l'inverse 56% nous disent que
l'absentéisme est très faible c'est à
dire moins de 10% des séances du conseil
municipal
je pourquoi je parle de ce sujet dans la
question des violences parce que
on le sait que les éléments qui sont
parfois déclencheurs de la non
représentation des mers c'est la
cohésion dans le conseil municipal et
l'absentéisme pour moi plutôt que de
chercher les indicateurs de toutes
sortes je dirais je veux pas en faire
une loi des reins mais quand il y a de
la santéisme on a un risque très sérieux
de non représentations du maire de non
représentations du maire donc parfois on
cherche des indicateurs à l'avance
plutôt que d'interroger le maire dit 12
18 mois avant l'élection je pense que
regarder
l'absentéisme ça serait ça serait
intéressant alors comment on peut
obtenir ces informations c'est très
compliqué parce que il faudrait déjà
qu'on a beaucoup de mal à avoir des
données c'est ce que j'évoquais hier
auprès du bureau des élections du
ministères à l'intérieur sur les causes
et nombre de démission n'ont pas des
mers mais les démissions des conseillers
municipaux moi je suis frappé quand
le nombre de formulaires CERFA qu'on
doit remplir pour se porter candidat on
pourrait peut-être imaginer une
procédure très simplifiée lors de la
démission d'un maire et aussi de sa
cause parce que là aujourd'hui on a on a
on n'a pas de visibilité que fait le
bureau des élections ils ont des relevés
des préfectures il regarde le répertoire
national des élus d'une année sur
l'autre et donc c'est ce que je disais
hier on annonce 910 d'émissions depuis
juin 2020
demeure 910 alors moi dans dans
l'ouvrage dont vous citiez
tout à l'heure le nom Françoise Gatel
entre 2010 et 2019
j'avais repéré qu'on était on avait eu
un point très très bas d'émission
jusqu'en 2014
alors il y a un aspect quand même
législatif qui a joué la loi notre bon
entre 2014 et 2009 on a une progression
on était en moyenne à 100 d'émissions de
mer par an à 350 en 2019 là si je prends
au sérieux il y a aucune raison de ne
pas dépendre ses chiffres du bureau des
élections 910 en date de février
2023 vous voyez ça veut dire c'est 30
mois bon ben 910 / 2,5 deux années et
demi en quelque sorte vous êtes à peu
près à 450 400 400 pardon 400 donc ça
progresse encore 400 d'émissions de
maire par an c'est pas négligeable
ce chiffre n'est pas négligeable quant à
au nombre de conseillers municipaux
démissionnaires je l'ignore
je l'ignore totalement on ne le on ne le
sait pas voilà pardon j'ai été un petit
peu long mais je suis évidemment
disponible poursuivre des changes merci
beaucoup martial pour ces informations
et cette analyse qui nous sont
extrêmement utiles avant de passer à la
législation que j'appellerais technique
le premier point qui est très
intéressant parce qu'on a beaucoup de
débats là-dessus c'est cette notion
d'égalité que le confond je pense trop
souvent avec l'uniformité l'égalité et
que ce que nos concitoyens attendent
effectivement c'est l'efficience de
l'action publique sur des domaines dont
je vous ai parlé je pense à l'école le
logement est Dominique et Sony est très
sensible la mobilité on vient d'en
parler avec les régions et que la
diversité des moyens est utile pour
exercer l'égalité droit et on cherche
pas forcément quand on habite dans une
ville de 10000 habitants à ressembler un
habitant une ville de 300 milles mais on
a un vrai sujet le deuxième point c'est
ce qu'on appelle
vous vous parliez de tension
démocratique l'acceptabilité ou la
légitimité de la décision d'un conseil
municipal et aujourd'hui on voit bien
que
l'acceptabilité est importante pour que
les élus puissent conduire leur action
publique et qu'on a donc cette obsession
de ce qu'on appelle la concertation
effectivement dans toutes les
professions de foi celui qui m'était pas
ça c'est même pas la peine qui sortent
des bulletins de candidats déjà alors on
y va c'est un peu comme la confiture
qu'on étale et alors on parle de
démocratie associative et que du coup on
donne parfois l'impression aux gens que
parce qu'ils sont concertés leur avis va
être la décision
que le
l'approche très individualiste de chacun
de nos concitoyens se transforment en
décision légitime c'est à dire c'est ce
que je dis qui doit être respecté et
qu'on a travaillé à la délégation avec
notre collection et chez nous le gap sur
ce sujet et nous on est arrivé à cette
notion de démocratie implicative
c'est-à-dire comment on fait de
l'habitant d'un territoire qui est un
individu un peu un citoyen en
l’impliquant sur des choses qui lui
plaisent c'est de manière légère et je
trouve que ça aide beaucoup à légitimer
la décision
et puis on a aussi parlé de la tension
démocratique avec la gestion des
conflits nous on a auditionné
le
garde des sceaux
vraiment auditionné d'une manière un peu
exigeante et sérieuse et on lui a
demandé ou en était le déploiement de ce
qui avait été voté dans la loi
engagement et proximité sur la
coopération entre les procureurs et les
élus
il y a des choses extrêmement
intéressantes qui se déploient et donc
il nous a même donné des chiffres par
département
de ce qui pouvait se passer et puis il y
a eu effectivement des conventions de
partenariats qui ont été signés entre
les associations départementales de mer
et notamment la gendarmerie pour
déployer des formations pour les élus à
la gestion de conflit alors moi j'ai
participé une de ces sessions qui se
déroule sur une demi-journée voilà c'est
remarquable parce que je pense que on
donne une sorte de kit de survie léger à
l'élu pour qu'il ait des réflexes
quand il se trouve en situation de
gestion de conflits qui se retrouvent un
peu piégé par des gens un peu nerveux
excités voilà donc ça ça se déploie
d'une manière
assez remarquable et je pense que l'AMF
doit avoir des chiffres de nombre de
conventions signées et ça c'est plutôt
pas mal et puis le dernier point avant
de savoir la mes collègues c'est le
délitement de l'équipe municipale ça
c'est un vrai sujet avec ce sentiment de
solitude du maire qui a besoin à un
moment d'avoir autour de lui une sorte
de Pâques qui fait que on va faire front
d'une manière positive à nos concitoyens
qui vont demander des choses quand le
maire se retrouve tout seul c'est très
dur il a affaibli et un moment le
découragement le découragement et là et
je pense que c'est aussi vous l'avez dit
un des éléments qui explique cette
situation
un peu peu préoccupante que l'on connaît
je ne serais pas plus longue j'ai passé
la parole Céline Molin
de Normandie et Antoine Lefebvre de
l'Aisne
merci présidente merci beaucoup pour
cet éclairage très intéressant
j'ai eu le sentiment que vous aviez peu
pris en compte mais peut-être je me
trompe
pour beaucoup alors sans tout expliquer
mais par exemple on a constaté sur le
terrain avec tous les voeux auxquels on
a participé ces temps-ci on a constaté
je dirais physiquement que des équipes
municipales
nouer je vais pas dire presque un
premier contact mais avec les habitants
au bout de deux ans
et c'est quand même quelque chose
d'assez
enfin qui ne s'était jamais produit
pareil pour les équipes municipales
le fait de faire équipe
se joue en général au début de mandat où
les gens apprennent à se connaître à
bosser ensemble
à expérimenter les compétences et
les les
particularités les aspirations des uns
et des autres et là il y a des tas
d'équipes qui ont dû travailler à
distance qui est quand même un peu
compliqué pour créer de la cohésion et
puis tout ça avec après l'enchaînement
des crises fait que
on a affaire à une population et les
élus échappent pas non plus à la règle
qui vit dans un sentiment d'inquiétude
permanente
de entre la maladie la guerre la crise
énergétique etc certains parlent de
grandes dépression etc et donc qui
génère je pense des comportements
sociaux qui peut-être
sont aussi de nature à expliquer les
tensions qu'on peut connaître il me
semble aussi que
à la faveur alors vous avez évoqué la
loi nôtre les interco etc mais on
pourrait évoquer la situation financière
on a des élus locaux qui finalement ont
de moins en moins de leviers d'action
quand la MF sont le titre du Congrès des
mères c'est c'était comment notre
pouvoir d'action là où est notre pouvoir
d'agir c'est-à-dire que ça veut dire
c'est que les élus locaux ils ont envie
d'avoir des leviers d'action ils en ont
de moins en moins et du coup
je pense que
la quand vous expliquez que 50% des
maires interrogés
s'inquiétaient de l'abstention ou enfin
la pensée peut-être structurelle plus
que conjoncturelle et que cette part
augmente
je pense que ça fait enfin ça traduit ou
ça fait écho à cette situation va
peut-être s'accroître ou s'accélérer
parce que les gens réalisent que nous
avons de moins en moins de leviers
d'action alors que les enjeux auxquels
nous sommes confrontés sont de plus en
plus aigus et que ça ça crée quelque
chose qui est très difficile à vivre je
pense pour les élus locaux et enfin pour
pas être trop longue
je partage complètement ce que vous avez
dit sur la prégnance de la perception
des inégalités territoriales je pense
qu'il y a vraiment c'est un lieu commun
mais qui a vraiment des tas de citoyens
et des locaux qui ont le sentent un
sentiment d'abandon ou qui ont le
sentiment d'être des élus ou des
citoyens de seconde zone et que ça c'est
extrêmement fort et que oui la présence
le maillage des services publics qui
sont quand même au-delà du service
concret qu'il rendent un symbole de
l'égalité républicaine je pense que ça
pèse très lourd dans cette perception et
dans cette réalité
merci merci beaucoup Céline peut-être
pouvons-nous faire si vous êtes d'accord
mais c'est intergrouper de questions
savoir
Antoine Lefèvre et ensuite notre
collègue
lancement merci madame la Présidente
merci à vous monsieur directeur pour
pour cette présentation à la suite
d'ailleurs de Céline j'avais aussi une
interrogation sur la la prise en compte
de ce début de mandat municipal qui a
été quand même particulier pour avoir
choisi enfin avoir été plus de 16 ans
maire de ma commune ayant fait le choix
de rester au conseil municipal je mesure
un peu les les difficultés il y a
beaucoup de d'éléments que vous avez
indiqué dans dans l'étude qui résonne
dans l'actualité j'étais lundi soir au
conseil municipal de ma ville avec
une position plus passive que je pouvais
par le passé mais je constatais que on
était alors je me suis dit mais il y a
un problème on est plus des vacances
chez nous il y avait sur deux un
conseiller sur deux n'était pas présent
enfin c'est assez compliqué et ça
rejoint finalement cette cette soirée
lundi ça rejoint un peu les thèmes que
vous avez abordé il y avait un gros
dossier sur un aménagement
urbain on parlait de concertation et
quand je regarde ce que fait mon
successeur il est plutôt enclin à
développer des outils de de concertation
de lui expliquer ce qui était un café
enfin bon des tas de choses et on lui en
a mis les oppositions lui ennuie plein
la tête par rapport à ça mais parce que
effectivement comme la suggérer
Françoise Gatel c'est un peu le la
notion de de concertation c'est devenu
de la codécision alors c'est un petit
peu compliqué et puis je reviens
justement à des éléments que vous avez
indiqué tout au début et je pense que
c'est une des explications que moi
j'avais dû du mal à vivre aussi c'est
que au fur et à mesure la la faiblesse
de la participation aux élections
municipales ce qui était quand même on
était la municipal a été relativement
épargné et souvent on se redressait
quand on était maire parce qu'on avait
cette légitimité et bien moi dès 2014 on
nous mettait les chiffres en face en
disant mais vous ne représentez que tant
de %
du corps électoral ou de la population
donc c'est un vrai sujet sur sur ces
éléments mais je pense que ça doit aussi
nous nous alerter parce que cette
défection de de
municipales en tout cas de la vocation
il faut vraiment préserver cela parce
que nous savons combien ici au
Sedat nous pensons que c'est essentiel
c'est toujours le premier échelon de
notre démocratie et si elle vacille si
elle va pas bien et je pense qu'on en
est là aujourd'hui il faut
urgemment intervenir pour pour faciliter
les choses à plusieurs niveaux et
l'étude en cela doit votre étude doit
nous aider à trouver un certain nombre
de solutions
merci beaucoup Antoine cher Laurent
oui ça va rebondir un peu sur ce que
vient dire Antoine effectivement vous
avez parlé du sentiment de perte de
légitimité
ma question c'était dans votre analyse
est-ce que vous avez un versus selon la
taille de la commune par rapport à cette
perte de légitimité est-ce que ça touche
les communes plus rurales que les
communes plus importantes la deuxième
c'est est-ce que parce qu'il y a une PPL
qui circule donc c'est l'occasion d'en
parler est-ce que les mers en tout cas
les personnes vous avez interrogé pense
que le vote obligatoire ou le vote blanc
est peut-être une solution tout
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont estimé que ça
pouvait être une solution à redonner
sens à la légitimité du résultat de
l'élection la deuxième chose c'est que
vous avez je partage complètement ce
qu'a dit Céline aussi sur le sentiment
d'inégalité territoriale mais ça je
pense qu'on pourrait le dire sur tout le
territoire national
j'aurais aimé avoir une une précision
quand vous avez dit à la crise des
gilets jaunes n'est pas épuisée même
avec le grand débat est-ce que c'est un
ressenti vraiment des mers ou c'est le
sentiment votre perception à vous par
rapport à ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
est-ce que c'est actuelle ou ce que
c'est sensoriel j'allais dire voilà
c'était un peu et puis le troisième
question où là je
j'avoue que je partage pas forcément je
dirais l'analyse vous en faites sur les
difficultés à discuter la violence dans
les rapports entre élus et population
par rapport à la au sentiment de
l'évolution naturel enfin j'allais dire
sociétale de la violence je pense que
c'est pour moi enfin me semble-t-il
c'est effectivement le report de cette
de cette évolution sociétale et de
l'extension de la violence dans les
rapports sociaux qui s'expriment aussi
dans les rapports à ceux qui
représentent l'autorité
merci pour vous pour vous remarques et
évoqué
je vais rassembler en trois en trois
briques
première brique sur la question crise
sanitaire et et les effets pour imaginer
en termes de effectivement de démission
c'est vrai que les équipes municipales
n'ont pas encore eu l'occasion de
fonctionner au moins durant les 18
premiers mois après après l'élection
donc
vous me donnez des pistes en fait à
creuser pour la prochaine en quête sur
la mer moi je préfère toujours regarder
ces choses là sans interroger
directement les élus mais trouvant des
moyens un peu détournés pour pour qu'ils
ne sente pas la question trop téléphoné
donc c'est un point qu'on va examiner
vous avez raison parce qu'il faudra on a
quand même une grande une grande
hétérogénéité des situations covid même
sur sur tout le territoire donc on
pourra regarder effectivement si on
observe des des cohésions d'équipes
municipale différentes selon la
prévalence de la situation que vide en
2020 2021
vous disiez effectivement que cela peut
entraîner des comportements sociaux
aussi
à tenir compte dans dans ces tensions
dans les communes
je vais vous je vais faire un léger
détour mais vous allez comprendre que
moi j'y accord d'une grande importance
et ça rejoint la
question sur
sur la légitimité par le vote je
considère que on a tort de penser qu'on
peut expliquer
les comportements politiques y compris
au plan local simplement
par nos grandes gris de lecture qui ont
été très très opérante et efficace
pendant 60 ans
c'est à dire tout ce qui est
objectivement
quel est votre âge votre condition
sociale votre profession
votre niveau de revenu votre sexe et je
vous dirais globalement si vous allez
être un abstentionniste
permanent intermittent
en fait tout cela aujourd'hui
fonctionne imparfaitement je dis pas que
ça ne fonctionne plus il y a une
dimension que moi j'essaye de travailler
depuis de longues années qui est le rôle
des émotions dans la décision électorale
et qui a été profondément révélée
pendant la crise covid je m'explique
toutes les dimensions c'est à dire
nonobjectif donc subjective les émotions
la question de la confiance
la question de ces notions d'optimisme
pessimisme bon on les travaille pas par
des des grandes catégories
socio-démographiques
chacun a une épreuve de vie qui le
conduit à mettre en avant sans que ce
soit conscient mettre en avant
la part subjective de chacun
alors il faut pas se tromper on se
réveille pas un matin en disant
aujourd'hui je vais être en colère ou
aujourd'hui je vais être anxieux
aujourd'hui je vais être confiant
vis-à-vis du maire et demain je ne serai
pas donc ce sont des processus très très
longs mais il faut toujours un fait
déclencheur
c'est à dire que ce que disent un
certain nombre de psychologues
il faut un moment ils appellent ça un
choc qui conduit une personne
effectivement à alors c'est pas la
raison contre la passion c'est ce serait
trop simple si c'était simplement cela
c'est qu'il y a des passions très
rationnelles
et puis vous avez une raison parfois
émotionnelle la parie curieux de parler
comme ça mais c'est une réalité face à
un choc on l'a vu après les attentats de
novembre 2015 en France et nous on a
continué à en 2017 et on l'a refait en
2022 a considéré que la situation
politique du pays pouvait être perçue
par des citoyens comme un comme un choc
qui
je dirais qui produit chez eux une
véritable un chamboulement de leur
propre représentation de leur futur
et pourquoi je dis cela pendant la crise
covid
je vais vous choquer peut-être
on dit que la France c'est le pays
européen ou le niveau de confiance
sociale vis-à-vis des autres et le plus
faible des pays européens d'accord donc
on a pas un capital de confiance il
était élevé vis-à-vis de l'entourage
familial il est quand même très élevé
mais la confiance qu'on qualifie dans
notre jargon interpersonnel vis-à-vis
des autres c'est l'entourage
familial mais aussi les collègues de
travail le voisinage les gens qu'on
rencontre pour la première fois les gens
d'une religion différente d'une
nationalité différente cet ensemble mais
la France vraiment en queue de peloton
de tous les indicateurs que l'on a
mesuré depuis maintenant plus de 20 ans
pourquoi j'ai dit je vais vous choquer
en fait ça a été un vrai salut pour
passer à travers la crise covid parce
que moi je fais un lien très très fort
si la France a été un des pays les plus
respectueux des mesures très
restrictives c'est que notre niveau de
confiance sociale étant si faible que
être en mesure finalement de s'en sortir
en s'affranchissant du besoin
d'interaction sociale ce besoin étant
tellement faible vous pouvez accepter je
le fais à grandir des nuances mais vous
pouvez facilement accepter ces mesures
dans la durée mais ça a un effet
considérable sur le sujet dont on parle
sur la cohésion sociale et le rapport
justement à l'autorité même locale
c'est que vous vous construisez
une individuation aux politiques on
l'observait en France depuis plus de 30
ans c'est à des rapports extrêmement
individuels par rapport à la sphère
marchande la consommation le
consumérisme et on disait tout ça c'est
le monde marchand c'est pour certains
c'est les effets d'un capitalisme qui
s'est presque qui est presque été rendu
sympathique maintenant ça touche la
sphère publique ça touche plus
simplement le bien privé ça touche le
bien public et le bien public c'est
aussi le rapport à l'élu et donc quand
vous êtes dans un rapport de plus en
plus individuel à la représentation bien
vous produisez des phénomènes des
comportements sociaux comme ce que vous
évoquiez donc je pense qu'il faut il
faut impérativement
c'est notre travail
davantage mettre en avant ce que
produisent les émotions dans les
réactions des citoyens au plan local
parce que sinon un maire ne comprendra
pas pourquoi
tel personne telle administrée est en
colère contre une décision qu'il n'a pas
du tout anticipé
et moi je je dis toujours je préfère
être face à une personne anxieuse qu'une
personne en colère parce que d'un point
de vue psychologique quand vous êtes
anxieux vous avez peur d'une situation
que vous n'avez pas anticipé vous n'avez
pas envie qu'elle se reproduise parce
que vous avez été surpris
vous êtes en fait quelqu'un de
raisonnable parce que vous êtes prêt à
réviser vos propres croyances sur ce qui
s'est produit et vous allez mobiliser
des ressources pour éviter que ça se
reproduise donc on va essayer en général
les personnes anxieuses privilégiez
toujours le statut quo une forme de
conservatisme social qui une personne
est en colère c'est pas du tout la même
histoire
vous n'êtes plus en situation de
l'accompagner pour réviser ses propres
croyances de sa compréhension d'un monde
qui lui échappe
et là je pense que l'élu quel qu'il soit
local ou national n'est pas aujourd'hui
outillé pour canaliser des décolère
social donc ça je pense qu'il faut c'est
un c'est un travail qui ne relève pas
isolément d'un élu sur tel et tel
territoire l'élu va le subir il ne peut
que le subir et j'insiste sur un point
parce que je vois pas qu'il y ait une
confusion la colère produit ne produit
pas nécessairement des violences
c'est pas cela ça peut être on se met en
dehors du jeu politique on est en colère
on ne veut plus participer aux élections
on est en colère on ne veut plus prendre
part à la vie associative culturelle etc
et donc ça joue parce que c'était le la
deuxième des trois briques dans vos
commentaires et questions sur oui
effectivement le pouvoir d'agir vous
avez raison de dire c'est un risque que
les maires veulent agir ça je pense que
beaucoup d'entre eux ils sont fortement
fortement attachés mais agir dans un
moment où sage j'en ai pas parlé mais
dans l'enquête on le voit bien quand je
vous disais que il ne finalement ils
veulent ils veulent qu'on cesse ce jeu
consistant à donner des des compétences
mais en retirant les moyens d'exercer le
financement de ses compétences
je crois que pour les élus alors tous
non effectivement pas fait une thèse de
droit sur la décentralisation mais
ils ont bien compris ce que ça voulait
dire en termes de responsabilité
politique et d'imputabilité moi j'adore
ce mot utiliser par les par les
Québécois pour parler de la
responsabilité on est imputable on est
comptable et être comptable mettre en
place des politiques municipales qui
restent qui sont de moins en moins
importantes mais si en plus vous n'avez
pas
l'outil de financement et donc la
fiscalité locale c'est incompréhensible
pour tout le monde cette
incompréhensible donc ça aussi ce sujet
de la fiscalité locale on l'a pas abordé
ça va être le thème de la prochaine
enquête faire un gros module sur la
fiscalité locale pour moi c'est le point
essentiel pour redonner
ce substrat de légitimité non pas
politique mais de l'action publique
parce qu'il y a rien de pire que de dire
je suis en permanence j'aimerais mettre
en place politique mais vous voyez je
n'ai pas les moyens alors ça pour un
pour un pour un maire c'est une sorte
presque d'affront par rapport à
l'engagement
et sur les services publics
sur les services publics oui vous avez
raison moi aussi je l'observe
on a demandé on a demandé à France
stratégie de nous il travaille sur des
nouvelles
nouvelles typologies de de
mince de définition
[Musique]
des gradients urbains etc donc ils font
quelque chose d'assez intéressant on
leur a demandé de nous donner beaucoup
d'éléments et on a croisé cela nous avec
nos données
j'arrive à deux conclusions très simples
oui il y a beaucoup plus de maisons
France services ouvertes mais en fait
les Français
n'y sont ni plus ni moins attachés
c'est-à-dire que si la maison France
service je prends un exemple parce que
je trouve qu'il est très révélateur si
la maison France service vous fait
déplacer d'une dématérialisation d'un
certain nombre de procédures de votre
salon dans un autre salon qui est celui
de maison France service
vous ne réglez absolument pas la
question de la perception d'un service
public qui se délite d'accord ça c'est
le premièrement deuxième exemple
puisque je suis quand je suis arrivé
vous vous avez ok avec le président
région de France la question du
ferroviaire mais dans ces territoires le
ferroviaire ça a une portée symbolique
d'une puissance inouïe c'est à dire
beaucoup de effectivement
un axe que je connais très bien entre
Paris et Clermont-Ferrand
et c'est pas le seul Paris Limoges c'est
la même chose
les gens ne comprennent pas pourquoi
le service public français n'est pas en
mesure
de d'investir sur un bassin de
population aussi important et donc la
représentation que se font les Français
sur le service public c'est pas de dire
le maire est responsable que la gare est
fermée non mais voyez ça produit cette
délégitation de l'action publique et
pour vous répondre monsieur sénateur sur
je
n'ai pas dit que ce qui se passe dans la
société n'a pas de répercussion je
disais plutôt c'est à dire je suis très
mal à l'aise avec cité cette idée de
dire qu'il y a une forme d'automaticité
ce qui se passe dans la société
automatiquement ou mécaniquement
rejaillit dans les comportements au
niveau municipaux je serai d'ailleurs
j'ai pas d'éléments pour vous dire que
ce ne serait pas vrai je ne le sais pas
très honnêtement en revanche
vous voyez le lien avec le service
public ferroviaire c'est c'est il est
évident que le ce sentiment de
relégation on l'utilise parfois à tour
de bras et la presse et la PQR peut
facilement l'utiliser mais c'est une
réalité objectivable la relégation
territoriale pour beaucoup de de
français donc c'est quand même pas loin
de 20 millions de Français vivant dans
les communes de moins de 3500 habitants
bon cette relégation territoriale elle
est de plus en plus mal perçue c'est
pour ça que je dis que le sujet gilet
jaune n'est pas totalement épuisé c'est
ma lecture ce n'est pas le ce n'est pas
la la les déclarations ou ce que j'ai pu
retirer des enquêtes auprès des mers moi
je continue à penser que c'est un c'est
le couvercle a été mal reposé en quelque
sorte et pour finir non le vote
obligatoire je n'ai pas posé la question
dans l'enquête nous n'avons pas posé en
revanche du côté
des citoyens là on l'avait on l'avait
conduit dans l'enquête avec le cevipov
en 2022 c'est une majorité massive
contre le vote obligatoire
c'est pas loin de 80% des Français qui
ne veulent pas du vote obligatoire oui
et alors ça dépend comment vous le
présentez si vous dites dans une
question pour lutter contre l'abstention
seriez-vous d'accord pour que le vote
devient obligatoire vous allez avoir un
taux probablement un petit peu plus
élevé en faveur du vote obligatoire par
contre si vous présentez la question du
vote obligatoire comme étant voilà dans
l'absolu pour ou contre vocabulatoire
vous avez vous avez un rejet très très
massif pourquoi parce que c'est le
sentiment qu'on l'on vient s'ingérer
dans ce qui est un des droits civiques
les plus précieux des citoyens donc faut
faire attention aussi la manière dont on
récolte une opinion publique sur cette
question là
légitimité par strat
dans dans l'enquête on a massivement des
mers appartenant aux communes de moins
de 10000 habitants qui ont répondu j'en
ai alors le taux de représentativité
n'est pas si mauvais mais voyez entre 10
et 30
000 habitants ça doit faire environ 700
communes en France
donc rapporté au nombre total de
communes oui on a le même pourcentage de
mer mais c'est simplement c'est une
cinquantaine dans dans l'enquête donc ça
je pourrais vous les communiquer si vous
souhaitez par par strat mais on n'a pas
de grande grande différence à vrai dire
on voit pas de grandes différences
si j'ai oublié quelque chose n'hésitez
pas à me le dire
oui c'était la troisième question
c'était vous avez dit que la crise des
gilets jaunes je sais pas si c'est
semblé ou en tout cas les mères c'était
exprimé en disant qu'elle n'était pas
épuisé
oui dans ce
véritablement mon point de vue est pas
celui des maires on les a pas interrogé
sur cette sur cette question mais
d'ailleurs on l'a pas fait cette année
parce que ça aurait semblait hors-propos
mais en
2021 on avait interrogé lorsque nous
avions interrogé les mers on leur avait
posé un certain nombre de questions sur
le soutien à certaines des
revendications pas le mouvement dans sa
globalité mais certaines des
revendications moi j'ai été très surpris
que beaucoup d'émers contestaient les
formes de mobilisation et d'action
mouvement gilet jaune mais sur le fond
de certaines de revendications elles
étaient largement partagées largement
partagé
oui
merci martien
je partage ce que vous dites sur la
manière dont les mères ont parfois quand
j'ai accompagné ils l'ont pas stimulé
mais je regarde l'engagement qui a été
celui des mers
sur le recueil des doléances et qu'il y
a de on va dire de ce sentiment de
déclassement ce qu'on appelle la
signature à résidence dont on a beaucoup
parlé tout à l'heure avec les régions
qui sont je crois
dans notre architecture
de l'organisation de l'action publique
des acteurs majeurs sur ce que j'appelle
l'émancipation des territoires c'est le
fait de redonner par l'économie par les
mobilités une une espérance en tout cas
martial le temps de rencontre régulier
que nous avons avec vous il est toujours
extrêmement important parce que nous
avons naturellement tendance comme
chacun être sur le sujet technique que
je vais prendre un sujet dont on a
beaucoup parlé hier et qui a marronnier
ici au Sénat l'eau et l'assainissement
voilà donc on prend le sujet parce qu'on
veut apporter des on veut apporter des
réponses et que c'est important qu'on
essaie de grille de lecture et de temps
en temps ça nous aide à mieux comprendre
des choses et dans le travail qui
entreprit ici au Sénat dans ce groupe
transpartisan conduit par le président
l'archet comme il a déjà fait en 2020
et où on va réfléchir à la
décentralisation à la déconcentration
qui ne sont jamais que des outils pour
que comme vous l'avez dit au début
chacun de nos concitoyens soient
convaincus de l'efficience de l'action
publique il est un citoyen dont la
République se préoccupe et on sait la
place du maire qui porte parfois sur ses
épaules
l'incarnation de la République et le
fait que personne n'abandonne le citoyen
moi j'ai toujours cet exemple en tête
comme vous avez dans une vie personnelle
d'un citoyen moment très difficile c'est
un très grave accident c'est un sujet
dans son je sais pas quoi qui est là
pour incarner la solidarité
la solidarité nationale c'est le maire
souvent avec le gendarme et le pompier
et que en ce sens là la commune est
vraiment le cœur
je crois d'une société de de la
confiance et de la solidarité donc merci
beaucoup martial il nous suivrons au
prochain travaux avec intérêt parce
qu'ils sont très éclairs merci beaucoup
merci mes chers collègues je souhaite à
chacun une très bonne fin de semaine